you've got the continuing nut job in
North Korea with his wacky ICBM uh
trials where he's trying to demonstrate
a capacity to launch high cbms at the
continental United States
and then you've got China you've got the
ever-present risk of China and
you know I'm being told routinely by
officials in my government and in the
U.S government that it's only a matter
of time before we're at war with China
18 to 24 months is the time scale that
I'm being told
God forbid why in Hell's name do we
think that we can win a war with China I
do not know but in the context of all of
this do you think the Congress is going
to devote a lot of time and resources
and energy to pushing for a hugely
embarrassing expose to be revealed of
criminal corruption inside the military
and an intelligence establishment
concealing an alleged crash retrieval
and reverse engineering program
involving retrieve non-human technology
for the last 80 years I don't think so
in other words as important as we find
it we're like this is the most important
subject the government's like you don't
know how close to Annihilation we are
from other sources it's not the most
yeah I mean I'm being I'm talking all
the time to people in
the US government who genuinely want
this issue out but in the scheme of
things
they're more focused quite legitimately
on making sure that Ukraine has enough
has artillery shells to be able to take
out the command structure of the Russian
government
I mean I I I don't think uaps are as big
a priority as they should be
and that's the tragedy because as David
grush admitted to me in his interview
actually I don't think a lot of this is
in the so far so far broadcast interview
but he's deeply skeptical about the
reasons why we went for war in Iraq
you know um and Afghanistan you know a
lot of good men and women have died
they've given their lives
uh for a conflict in the Middle East
that it was of dubious dubious
prominence you know why I mean what
benefit was derived from fighting that
war
imagine if the trillions of dollars that
were expended on the Middle Eastern
conflict had instead been expended on
a Manhattan style project where there
was collaborative science between men
and women in science from all over the
world to develop Energy Technologies and
propulsion systems that could
revolutionize human civilization
that's what people are talking about
now I don't know for sure that that
technology exists because I haven't seen
it but I have spoken to people who've
told me that it does exist I have spoken
to people who've urged me to push for
the public disclosure of the existence
of this technology and that's one of the
reasons why David Rush has come forward
he's the first of many
but those other Witnesses are watching
on and they're seeing how David grush
gets treated if he's treated badly if
he's treated if he's treated parentally
and dismissed then the world doesn't
deserve to know frankly
and I mean I appeal to your I mean one
of the things I love about your show
Curtis you get in a phenomenally
well-informed audience you have highly
intelligent people mainly from science
but also thought leaders who are
listening to your show and they
understand that you give people like me
the time to explain and I I don't know
if I can begin to convey the depth of
emotion and frustration that good
science oriented people feel
that they can't talk publicly about what
they know that's being concealed right
there maybe they're lying to me maybe
the many people that I've spoken to have
all contrived to lie to me maybe it's
just a massive disinformation program
and maybe the whole U.S Congress has
been misled to the extent that they now
believe credulously that there might be
things of non-earth origin held within
private Aerospace
I suspect there is
and imagine the consequences for the
world if that's true
imagine if for example
there is a technological Discovery to be
made that could make fossil fuels
redundant overnight
exists
and if these Technologies exist as they
appear to do
that this is that this is the
frightening thing about this is this
dissonance between what we know the fact
that this technology clearly exists even
sean Kirkpatrick the the head of Arrow
is begrudgingly admitting that these
metallic spheres are anomalous and that
he cannot explain them and there's no
explanation for how they're manipulating
themselves under their own control when
they've got no visible means of
propulsion
you've got that something is doing
things we cannot explain right and yet
there is this credulous
media acceptance
of a continuing disinformation program
that is run now for 60 to 70 years that
we should just accept the glib
assertions of the Pentagon that Arrow
has no credible evidence to support
evidence of ET
well for one Arrow wouldn't know because
it's not set up to do that job
it's not set up to proactively
investigate you just watched a clip from
the theories of everything channel for
the full video and all its magnificence
then click here and if you'd like to see
more then subscribe enjoy